the time and you know it survival value
in men men are designed to look for
replication value women yeah I think
it's like I think it's unfair to like
completely rule that out because I feel
like it's fair for a man to be able to
do that you are allowed to have a moment
and this is okay unpopular opinion this
is one of the traits that I think men
Overlook in women now
just personal opinion okay this isn't
I'm probably biased because I'm a woman
um but I also look at the women that my
brothers chose that I really like
now
I think that men Overlook work ethic
from women because here's the thing like
you don't want a girl that's like lazy
and sitting around the house all the
time you don't want that if you're going
to train a girl she's got to work hard
to be trained being a
molding yourself to a man isn't easy
it's not easy if you want a girl that
works hard to like learn to cook learn
to like whatever it is work ethic's
important and but men aren't attracted
to it like women are attracted to that
men don't really care like it's just
kind of there but I feel like that's one
of the things that men Overlook in women
because I'll see it all the time where
it's like
a guy will date a girl but she's lazy
and she's like pretty and she's fun but
she's lazy so long term
you know she just like doesn't do
anything and then he's like working I'm
cleaning around the house she's not
helping him in any way you know just
personal opinion but you can take that
or leave it it's an Fair thought okay
life's not fair but I think you should
be allowed your moment of weakness and I
kind of feel like from a woman's
perspective it would be then how you
then deal with that I think you should
end world hunger I also think that we
shouldn't have nuclear weapons and
people shouldn't be dying needlessly Etc
but I can't operate and should couldn't
would I operate on what is and what is
is that women and that's what I talk
about this I don't tell the world what
to be it just is what it is I don't I
don't want guys to have four wives but
[ __ ]
there's a dude in Africa I guess I had
like over 100 wives like over 200 that's
crazy
apparently unattracted to weak men and
crying and showing vulnerability is a
component to that no so you wouldn't cry
in front of me absolutely not never you
would never see that
have you ever been in love
to a woman
yeah
I've had love for women but I don't
think yeah I don't think it's a man in a
man's best interest to be in love with a
woman but if you lose control so I feel
like
um everything and your standpoint on
women is going to change the moment you
like meet the right woman
yeah that's cute but no I mean uh I I
have I've had love for women but I'm
never going to fall in love with a woman
because when you fall in love with a
woman what happens is you start to lose
grounding and you start to lose that
rational thought a lot of the stupid
things that men do is because of love so
you're scared to be vulnerable no and
let yourself go and be in love like
you're gonna block yourself
from like emotion and to fill for
something that could be really amazing
for you because she's got to be
vulnerable no because I understand that
men and women are different and Men love
women far differently than women I do
think it's better when the woman loves
the man whether the man loves the woman
my mom would say the opposite she would
say it should be the other way around
but she's a woman we don't even know
what we want
men love women for real women love men
women love men for real no they don't
women love men under the premise that
they provide value men love women
idealistically women tend to love men
more from an opportunistic standpoint
yes you don't no I've almost can I just
say all men say they don't and they
actually do I really don't you've never
done it in your life no I've done in my
life so yes but the last time I did it
was 2014. I remember specifically once
yeah never again
[Music]
female vaginas are disgusting no they're
not do you eat vagina
exactly poor Improvement
no point proven you don't do it why
should I do it listen a woman's body is
beautiful she was bi
if you're bi you don't however you buy
if you don't
okay what I don't understand is like why
it's such a Stern now because why
wouldn't you want to please
your woman you know because have you not
ever like I said before it's a woman's
job to please a man out the other way
around no that is actually ridiculous
when it comes to being intimate and in
the bedroom
it's not it's like when Once when you do
something for someone have you not seen
how and they like it have you not seen
how much they perform better and I'm not
just talking sexually like in general I
don't want to say like an [ __ ] but a
woman's ejaculation is irrelevant
you only need one ejaculation to create
life and that's demands now with that
said does that mean I'm not going to
please my girl or whatever of course I
will but it's elective definition in
beds just like a woman's you know duty
to go to work is elective my duty to
please her sexually is elective that's
ridiculous how's that ridiculous because
no oh you know how about this with that
logic
stop paying the bills yeah and then you
lose attraction for me wouldn't you
[Music]
because I just don't understand why like
just I feel if you just started doing it
you might have a bit of like
relationship well no I women might not
your woman might not like it but I'm
just saying from a sample I don't
understand why you have to constantly
dominate even in this scenario like
having sex is an intimate thing it's an
energy exchange energy Exchange
more typical female gibberish like bro
energy exchange what the hell bro get
out of here with that I'm right I hate
it when girls say that too they say it
all the time on the podcast we exchange
energies and I'm like
I I understand what they're saying a
little bit from like a woman's point of
view
but men don't see it that way we we give
them something
they take it they ain't giving us [ __ ] I
I don't know how this [ __ ] works but
yeah
yeah really beautiful thing so why would
you not want to make her feel good most
women get off on you getting off that's
the truth
[Music]
if we're going to be all the way about
this no no no no women thought that no
no women used to think that through porn
really everything like yeah yeah okay
but and this is what I'm saying but
women have started to Persian ourselves
doing things and now we know how nice
certain things feel women are more
miserable now than ever before
everything now that's true that's true
there's more women on antidepressants so
you can't you can't really argue
argue women derive their pleasure from
serving a man they love in my respect
and their children I provide
so then you got to provide the
ejaculations
I don't know what's hard
it's true I mean like a man if a man's
marrying you or with you a long time you
should give him sex I just yeah I don't
know why you would fight that God if
you've been serious or you're actually
like I mean I think you can kind of
build a bond with a woman through other
stuff but you know
I don't really care people can do what
they want
a guy getting his girl off is elective
let me see Candace bushel is one of the
producers of Sex in the City and regrets
choosing her career life instead of a
family because now she's 16 alone
Pearl you're great but is there anything
you disagree with Myron on
I'm gonna just keep going do it but they
don't have to just like I think a man
has to work in his woman okay we'll just
do it and then just see what you get
different results that's what I'm saying
I don't do that I'm not and if that and
if that's what she like needs to get off
well too bad not doing it well yeah
because that's a submissive thing too
that like I'm not what is your issue
with men submitting to women I genuinely
girl you know we don't want a man that
submits to us that's like the first way
to get us to leave this is a big issue
of yours oh really okay yeah so what I'm
saying but I'm just saying don't go into
don't don't worry don't go into it
because you're about to go into it I'm
just saying genuinely you have such an
issue with just you don't like when I
use your logic on you he has definitely
got some issues no I just don't like the
fact that you it's this power dominating
thing that you want as a man like yes
you can have it but just in some
situations just know when to also submit
as a man and surrender not everyday
masculine man
I'm glad you find it funny absolutely
not we will not cons we don't negotiate
with terrorists
[Laughter]
have been dogs yeah I used
I used that women were reasonable
until I did my podcast I don't anymore I
won't lie to you guys I'm just being
honest
some luminar but by and large we are not
terrorists what's the relationship like
with the women in your life like family
wise fantastic it's actually my mom that
taught me a lot of I grew up in a Muslim
household so she was the one that told
me don't commit to these Western women
blah blah
um so my mom is actually like a very
strong
um symbol in my life when it comes to
navigating uh this situation if it
weren't for her I'd probably be a simp
you know really um yeah I mean I grew up
in a but my parents were together to
this day my man my my dad my dad was the
man my mom was the woman my dad LED my
mom followed and you know they they have
a fantastic relationship and a big part
of that is because they they you know
stuck to their roles and it was my mom
that told me from a young age don't
don't marry these Americans I want to be
that mother
these women ain't [ __ ] son these women
ain't [ __ ] like you can't trust them
she said she was a vert okay okay I mean
these Western women they're not gonna
cook and clean for you they're not gonna
um they're not gonna take care of you
you're gonna come to the home it's gonna
be the shovel blah blah I used to think
to myself like Mom chill what's wrong
with you but as now that I'm 32 versus
being 12 20 years later I'm able to look
back on that advice and be like God damn
mom would spend some heat back in the
day yeah it makes sense yeah so it's
understandable why it's like you think
the way that you think because of your
environment and your influence which is
which is a good thing for you my my
background right like I didn't like at
first it was like okay I don't agree
with this right because I used to be
like you know growing a grown-up
American I was born in Connecticut I was
like Mom you're wrong like women aren't
like that what's wrong with you blah
blah blah like you're you're a
misogynist mom and you've got some
ingrained massaging you right you even
said that like I I back then I don't
even think I knew what that word was uh
that's like a buzz term nowadays that no
one knows the definition of anyway but
anyway
um
so as I got older right like the things
that she started to say started to
reflect more and more when I dealt with
more and more girls and I was like what
the hell is going on here and talking
with other men talking with you know
with women Etc my experiences like and
then talking with thousands of men and
then also talking about I'm in a very
unique position where I've talked to
both both genders on on a podcast
coaching sessions Etc so I'm gonna you
know very certain situation where I'm
able to get anecdotal evidence I have
statistics Etc to back up what I'm
saying and I would say my approach to
dealing with women dating relationship
sex Etc is a very pragmatic way to
approach the dating Marketplace based on
today's scenarios with this dating
advice working in 1950s maybe not
because women were different back then
but nowadays do you think don't think
women were different that's what I was
thinking I think women just had less
opportunity and more consequences back
then but I think women have always been
hypergamous I was at this Art Museum and
there were some women that were like
leaving their families and they got
stoned to death in like the description
I'm like I think women have always been
like this
it says no one dates Pro unless Auntie
Jenny bets them oh yeah Auntie Jenny's
sending me on dates
um and T Jenny you can put your
Instagram in the description or whatever
but yeah basically
Auntie Jenny has going to vet
guys and send me on dates with them so
yeah also I started my I started my
cookbook today just so you know with
Auntie Jenny
they're significant they're
significantly different like from a more
negative standpoint not to a man's
benefit
over okay nice yes it's a hell no
unacceptable disgusting hurray I've
never wipe that girl up recreational use
only 30 is a lot
that's a lot 30 is a lot
why a hell no
it was yours
what's my body count
what's the uh the term in England when
you don't want to when you want to
invoke the Fifth Amendment but you can't
no comment no comment there we go no
comments
is yours over 200
300
yours is a lot more Sparta wow and you
wanna it's yours is over 300 and you
want to get mad at 30. this this isn't
even a double standard anymore like he's
just taking it too far I think it's more
attractive if a man doesn't because if
you can no it is like if you can show
discipline why are you laughing yeah no
because if for me it shows like
self-control and discipline it's because
when we say that we just mean we don't
want a guy that slept with a bunch of
people we know that's what we mean
because that's like embarrassing it's
like ah he had yeah
I've left to their own devices want to
have sex with as many women as possible
men are designed to spread seed we want
quantity women are designed to protect
their egg for the best seed women want
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible